والى ملف الحربي في اوكرانيا وحدات من
الجيش الروسي تستمر بضرب اماكن تمركز
القوات الاخرانيه فيما تستمر كيف في
محاوله استعاده اراضيها التي سيطرت عليها
موسكو بدعم غربي وفي اخر التطورات
الميدانيه تم اعلان حاله التاهب الجويه في
كيب ومدن اوكرانيه اخرى تحسبا لهجمات
الروسيه فيما افاد الجيش الاوكراني بوقوع
قذف الروسي استهدف مدينه اوديسا كما افادت
وسائل الاعلام من اوكرانيه بوقوع سلسله
انفجارات في دينك
اولى زخات الثلوج اذا مشاهدينا سقطت في
فصل الشتاء في كيب في الوقت الذي تواجه
فيه العاصمه الاوكرانيه انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي بسبب سلسله جديده من الضربات
الروسيه التي تستهدف البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه
نتابع مع مراسي لينا من كيف ومن دونيتك
حذيفه عادل ورائد الاخبار مرحبا بكما ااا
ابدا ااا معك حذيفه عما اسفر القصف الروسي
اليوم وكيف يتعايش الاوكرانيون كذلك مع
انقطاع الكهرباء
[تصفيق]
حذيفه تسمعني
كيف
طيب طيب
سالتك عن التطورات الميدانيه كان هناك قصف
عنيف اليوم على المدن الاوكرانيه من قبل
روسيا هل من تحديث للمعطيات عما اسفر عن
هذا القصف
نعم في الحقيقه صهيب 70 قذيفه
دمار كبير في بعض المناطق السكنيه وايضا
طبعا استهدف بعض المواقع للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه
اربعه اشخاص في منطقه في مدينه
كان هنالك
قتل شخص نتيجه القصف الذي طال هذه المنطقه
وبشكل عامل
تغيرات كبيره خاصه
الروسيه تتقدم نحو هذه المدينه الهامه
التي اذا ما استطعت السيطر عليها تكون على
بعد كم من همم
منطقه الصنافاس واكرامي
في منطقه
الاوكرانيه عن العكس تتقدم وقال ان القوات
الاوكرانيه اصبحت قريبه من المدن الكبرى
همم
جونسكو من روبيزني اليوم ايضا كان هنالك
عمليات تفكيك للذخيره في سنغاف كافي لوكا
وانفجرت بعد المتفجرات نتيجه عمليه
التفتيك حتى ان قتل بعض الفنيين الذين
كانوا يعملون في عمليه تفكيك المتفجرات في
هذه المنطقه نعم الى دونيتك رائد اسالك
كذلك عما اسفر القصف الاوكرانيه على دمبرز
يعني في الحقيقه حتى هذه اللحظات
تسقط هناك من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه حسب
تصريحات السلطات المحليه وهنا خصم متبادل
ما بين
الانفصال والقوات الاوكرانيه لكن همم
السلطات تشير الى تقدم القوات الروسيه
والمواليه لروسيا في عده محاور اهم المحور
الشمالي الغربي حيث بعد السيطره على مدينه
نيويورك
التي تقاتل في مدينه
حذيفه انها تتقدم في هذه المدينه ووصلت
الى وسط المدينه وتدفع القوات الروسيه
للانسحاب وهذا محور هام جدا لجانب
الانتصار حيث انقطاع المياه التي تحصرها
مدينه
المدن المحيطه بمدينه لها اهميه كبيره هي
التي تقصف قلب المدينه باستمرار تقدمت
القوات الانفصاليه وسيطره على مدينه على
بلده
اطراف مدينه افديركا وايضا تتقدم فيبقى
المحور الجنوبي وهو حول اوغلودار سيطره
القوات ايضا المواليه لروسيا على عده
بلدات اطراف وتتقدم نحو هذه المدينه
المتاخمه لمدينه اداء المحور الشرقي
متبادل لكن هناك ضحايا من المدنيين في
زبرجه
او مدينته همم
كيف اكد اشعر بها هنا تنتقل عبر الصوره
وهي تمطر عندك بغزاره كمان نشاهد معك رائد
شكرا جزيلا لكم على عكس طبعا تطورات الحرب
يعني همم الجو بارد والحرب ساخنه شكرا
جزيلا لكم على هذا التحديث اذا من دون يسك
رائد الاخبار ومن كيف حذيفه